hell cared a lot about the
and it's visual texture
you did several pictures with him what
was he like just shooting an Ashby
picture we never talked about the look
of of pictures I remember speaking of
Hal as a director but I think we should
think of him as a filmmaker and actually
my first contacts with Hal was black and
white picture called the best man with
Henry Fonda and then there were other
pictures that he did for Norman Jewison
that he was the editor but even in that
at that time in the heat of the night
Thomas Crown Affair kind of thinking
what other films we did but he'll was a
filmmaker before he was a filmmaker he
was a partner it was part of the
direction of a movie and he always came
from well the film we're going to see
Harold and Maude the director
photography was John Alonso and John and
he'll and I were also active with Cesar
Chavez and he'll always functions not
from other movies that he saw but he
functioned from life as he sensed it as
a as he realized that and and how he
tries to express it with with his images
as well as the story he told and and
that's why as a as a person he he exists
in in all of us some from just the film
as he sees and also most of a lot of it
for people like myself who who knew him
for a long time
you
you